hi I'm Erik Bosse and the shape of water
is the most nominated film at this
year's Academy Awards fluting
nominations for Best Picture and Best
Director for camera del Toro del Toro is
one of our favorite directors here at
new rock stars over his career he's
carved out a niche of monster movies
with a heart to shape of water centers
on a mute janitor Eliza Sally Hawkins
who falls in love with a government lab
sea creature portrayed by Doug Jones it
still tours latest and most celebrated
monster film and it does something
unique compared to other stories like
this that might be why so many critics
and audiences are connecting with it Wow
a lot of elements in the shape of water
work beautifully the production design
the music the performances that's look
closely at this movie's ending and
deeper meaning to understand why it's so
effective and spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the shape of water so at
its core the shape of water is a beauty
and beast tale a classic formula and
storytelling that's literally a tale is
all this time a woman falls for a
creature who ends up being kinder and
more human than most men suggesting that
inner beauty is more virtuous than
external attractiveness and many
examples the romance features a physical
transformation this dates back to Greek
myths which often ended in a
metamorphosis by characters so that
their outer form reflects their inner
nature shape of water hits all of these
classic story beats but with one key
difference
the lovers perspectives never change and
most films essential characters undergo
a shifting of values the way they see
the world at the beginning of the movie
is the opposite of how they see it at
the end of a movie and this is true for
most beauty in beasts tales in which the
lovers are initially repulsed by each
other and then eventually understand
their surprising common interests and
they fall for each other
and we all overlook how weird this is
that this is bestiality but not so for
the shape of water Eliza and the
amphibian man are infatuated at first
sight even before she meets the creature
Eliza has a metaphysical connection with
all things aquatic the opening shots
show her dreaming of living in an
undersea Kingdom she takes long
pleasurable baths she repeatedly boils
in water eggs symbols of her own
fertility that she later shares with her
new lover her courtship with this
creature proceeds linearly from here
they never fight they never misinterpret
each other they just fall deeper and
deeper in love and do increasingly
freaky things together but even though
these main characters do not change the
shape of water is still a story about
Ray
formation really the perspective that
changes in this movie is our own
represented by the supporting characters
Octavia Spencer as Zelda Richard Jenkins
as Giles Michael Stuhlbarg as Hostetler
aka Dmitry initially these people like
us view the creature as a monster a
source of mystery in danger over time
their views soften and they recognize
the beauty that Eliza saw from the
get-go
for example Giles art in the beginning
reflects a wholesome American family but
then after realizing mainstream society
will never truly embrace him his muse
instead becomes the creature
similarly late in the film Eliza's
musical dream sequence portrays the
creature as a trained ballroom dancer
this is essentially the Creature from
the Black Lagoon filling in for Fred
Astaire for seeing all of us to rethink
what we define is classically beautiful
this transformation is mirrored in the
devolution seen in the villain
Strickland played terrifyingly has
always been Michael Shannon he begins
the movie as the seemingly wholesome
American man but as time goes on he
reveals himself to be a physically
repulsive monster specifically the
festering wound on his hand disfigures
him into more of a beast than the
creature and by the end of the movie his
final words exemplified its dual shift
with Strickland voicing the on humility
before the creature that we all have in
this moment you are God the creature
carries the wounded Eliza into the water
where the scars on her neck open up as
gills physical transformation to reflect
the inner amphibian she always was the
outer nature finally matching the inner
but in this narration Giles admits at
this sweet epilogue that we're seeing is
really just one of his imagination he
doesn't really know what the lovers
fates are all the offers is the poem
that gives this film its title unable to
perceive the shape of you I find you all
around me your presence fills my eyes
with your love it humbles my heart for
you are everywhere from a literal point
of view the shape of water is whatever
the shape of its container is throughout
the film Eliza and the creatures take
the shape of their containers fishes in
a tank until finally they are released
and like water their love spreads all
around this is what Giles is telling us
here this is how he interprets the end
of their story as an observer his
shifted perspective and choice to see
this as the takeaway points of this
film's deeper message about what it
needs to be a misfit just as the lovers
were misfits who never truly
along dunland Giles Zeldin Dimitri are
also misfits in a society that sees them
as less than human Giles as an aging
homosexual in the 60s and a struggling
advertising artist Zelda as a
blue-collar african-american woman in
pre Civil Rights Baltimore and Demetria
is an isolated Soviet scientist at the
height of the Cold War in America but
the two central lovers are the biggest
misfits of this movie and they free
themselves as a representative example
for us that as misfits we're not meant
to change ourselves to fit in we just
need to find someone who is as much of a
misfit as we are and let that love
spread like shapeless water yes may we
all find a fish to have sex with but I'm
curious to hear from you guys here do
you see this ending as happier set like
did you interpret Giles is narrated in
being with Eliza surviving as an
amphibian as literal or do you see it as
metaphorical representing Eliza and the
creatures immortal love and escape from
a restrictive Society I can see
arguments either way so I want to know
what you think comment with your
thoughts down below and tweet me
directly at da vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates under videos like and share
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars or deeper looks at great films
like our recent analysis of Logan's
screenplay and a breakdown of John
Williams's music for Star Wars the last
Jedi and if you really want to help this
channel you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Laurie Denning thanks for
watching